tonight's we're in Boulder City to find
out what ghostly Secrets lie within the
town limits
we start at the corner of Nevada way in
Wyoming back in 1947 it was the home of
reservation Cafe and a gas station
tragically on October 30th the Cafe's
owner dick likins and his friend aerosol
Telford died in a plane crash nearby
there are reports that their spirits
still haunt the area which is now home
to beer zombies here is Paranormal
expert Joshua Warren with more I
personally saw an entire glass of beer
fly off of this table with your own eyes
with my own eyes it flew off shattered
in the corner I mean there was this
burst of energy that you could detect in
the air employees talk about hearing
voices after closing when nobody's
around catching glimpses of Shadows
darting around but the hauntings don't
stop on the ground back in 2021 Jason
srirachi of paranormal Vegas captured
this ghost plane passing an actual plane
near Boulder City you can see the ghost
plane on the left could it be lichens
and Telford enjoying one last flight
back on the ground there is certainly an
unexplained energy inside the bar this
is called a tri-field natural em meter
and it picks up any type of natural
electrostatic anomaly and basically this
meter should always remain constant and
steady so what we do is we observe it to
see if we get any type of a bump or any
type of a strange energy field that
might be
ah now we're picking up definitely a
strong field right around this table
with this backup meter oh we're picking
up something right now
we want it to be steady but the fact
that it's now changing means there's
energy around it yes you're not moving
I'm not exactly Joshua why is this area
so haunted
this town was created to house the
workers for the Hoover Dam project and
there was a lot of tragedy associated
with that project in fact the very first
man who died
he was a surveyor in 1922 who fell off
of a barge and drowned
the last man who died was his son and he
died on the exact same day 13 years
later when he fell off of the tower oh
my God they're very spooky about this
whole area absolutely and those those
fears those presents live among us
that's exactly right almost 100 men died
during that project JC we are at the
Boulder City Company Store and there is
a ghost in this historic photo taken at
the original Company Store this photo
taken in Boulder City yes
real oh right there yep oh my gosh look
how clear that is that is stunning you
can see the Hat the tie perhaps and
typical Garba about someone that was
gonna be working on the dam at the time
that would be the right kind of wardrobe
for the period we end our evening at the
Boulder Dam Hotel which was built in
1933 to accommodate visiting government
officials in dignitaries but as Legend
has it the hotel houses a secret down
below at Cleveland's Speakeasy The Story
Goes that a murdered person was buried
secretly somewhere on this property and
to this day people see this Apparition
of a man wearing a dark suit a dark hat
floating around Cleveland Speakeasy okay
I'm already starting to get chilled as
you're telling me this story can one of
your tools pick up something sometimes
when a ghost appears you get a cold spot
yes this is a thermal imaging camera and
I'm going to scan the room to see if I
can find one of those cold spots
floating around okay there is a cold
spot right back in that corner and that
is one of the places where this figure
is most often seen what's the cold is
about we're looking at on the camera
what are we saying that redness in the
center there what we're seeing is this
whole blue patch oh my God there's
nothing there no
there's definitely something hovering in
that corner turns out we're not the only
ones picking up a reading back in 1980
psychic Patsy welding walked the
property and she refused to enter the
basement saying something Waits there as
for me I wasn't willing to wait around
to discover anything else Joshua thank
you so much I've heard though is it true
that spirits can follow you home oh yeah
it happens all the time is there a trick
to have them not follow you home there
is a traditional blessing that may help
from ghosties and Ghoulies and Things
That Go Bump in the night good Lord
Deliver Us
no no I'm out of here